outriders is now out and you'll likely
notice that developer people can fly
shooter rpg hybrid is
fairly straightforward that said there
are a few features and mechanics that
the game quickly glosses over or never
explains
and they're quite helpful to know so
here's 10 tips to help you become a top
tier outrider
if you find these tips helpful and want
to keep up to date on outriders as well
as a few other shooter rpgs
be sure to subscribe sure you have
plenty of incredible superpowers and
outriders but each class has a pretty
devastating melee attack too
in a pinch these melee attacks can save
you when you're backed against a wall
and waiting for one of your abilities to
recharge but their primary use
is offense and sometimes there's no
better way of beginning your attack than
running straight at the enemy encampment
when you use a melee attack while
sprinting your character will leap into
the air and slam down on the ground to
deliver an area of effect explosion
a powerful opening move to any attack
especially if you're playing as the
tank-like devastator or rogue-like
trickster and are looking to get up
close and personal anyway
in outriders you'll find loot all the
time and the game does a really good job
of constantly drip feeding you better
and better firearms and armor
early on just keep selling the old and
equipping the more powerful this will
not only help you take on the early game
bosses with the ideal power level allow
you to experiment with a lot of
different types of weapons
don't grow too attached to anything and
speaking of finding better gear don't
forget to explore
every inch of the new areas you discover
more often than not the larger areas and
outriders will hide one if not two
chests
these chests are a great way to find
good gear and they're hidden all over
you can pretty much always count on
finding at least one in areas where you
fight a mini boss
after the intro chapters of outriders
you'll unlock crafting
here's where you should start paying a
little bit of attention to what you loot
keep upgrading to the best you have but
whenever you find rare or epic items or
if you're
really lucky legendary items take the
time to look at the mods they have when
those weapons and armor are no longer up
to snuff dismantle them instead of
selling them this will give you the mods
on those items so you can then craft
onto any rare or epic weapon or armor
you find
additionally you can change how a gun
behaves to better fit your ideal
playstyle like adjusting a fully
automatic gun to be
burst fired be sure to mod your gear
often every time you ditch an old piece
of gear for something new
which again you should be doing all the
time take the opportunity to craft your
favorite mods onto your new gear so that
you can continue to dominate with your
ideal playstyle
provided you keep selling all the gear
you don't need and taking a few seconds
to mine for resources as you come across
them in missions you'll be swimming in
the necessary materials for crafting
if you're at all worried about missing
out on loot turn on outrider's autoloop
feature
open the options menu and navigate to
the gameplay tab where you should see a
slider that you can adjust in order to
determine what type of weapons and armor
you want to autoloot
by default outriders will allow any and
all players to join your game if you
don't want folks randomly jumping into
your game you'll need to adjust your
privacy options
open the options menu and go to the
gameplay tab from here you should see an
option to change your game privacy you
can adjust it so that only
your friends on your chosen hardware can
join your game or close your game off
entirely requiring folks to get an
invite from you
in order to join as you level up you'll
unlock points that you can invest into a
skill tree you won't be able to unlock
enough points to buy
every skill across all three branches
but don't sweat things too much
not only can you respect your skill
points whenever you want you can do so
freely so experiment with different
skills and see what might work best for
your chosen build
on top of that you can respect your
skill tree in order to help out your
loot game when you're farming for better
gear certain skills in each class's
skill tree make your character better
with certain weapons
and allow them to more easily find those
weapons if you're curious all four
classes feature a skill that helps them
farm for assault guns like
assault rifles and light machine guns
however only the devastator and
trickster have a skill to help them farm
for shotguns
and only the pyromancer and technomancer
have a skill for helping them farm for
rifles and snipers
just because you unlock a new world tier
doesn't mean you always have to play
at that world tier you should play on
the highest world tier you've unlocked
as often as possible just to ensure
you're still getting loot drops that
will boost your power level
however if you're stuck on one fight
just lower your world tier get past it
and then raise the world here again
afterwards there's no penalty for doing
so and it's better than frustratingly
throwing yourself at the same section of
the game for longer than you have to
every time you unlock a new world tier
you'll get a new reward
in order to accept the reward you need
to open the world tier menu it won't
unlock automatically
early on your rewards aren't much to
write home about as they're largely low
level gear or resources
however you'll eventually start to get
epic and legendary loot so don't forget
to claim those rewards in order to
unlock some powerful armor or weapons
and those are the tips and tricks we've
come up with so far if you notice
anything in out writers that you think
other folks should know comment below
and be sure to subscribe so that you
don't miss out on our coverage of
outriders like our video review
you